you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live
however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at
[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello and listening friends welcome to
Bible answers live would you like to
hear an amazing fact back in 1912
Wallace Hartley faced a difficult
decision he'd been given an incredible
job opportunity but it meant a long time
away from his fiancee Maria she
understood a professional musician often
traveled that's why she gave him a
silver engrave plaque for his violin
with the message for Wallace on the
occasion of our engagement from Maria
Wallace decided to accept the important
job opportunity it would be a valuable
foundation for their future together
so in April 1912 he set sail as the band
master on what was then the largest ship
ever built the RMS Titanic but just four
days later in the cold dark early
morning hours of April 15 Wallace
gathered the ship's seven musicians
together taking his violin engraved with
Maria's message he had led them in
playing music to help keep passengers
calm as they realized they had too few
lifeboats to escape the doomed sinking
vessel witnesses later reported the
music played to nearly the very end
none of the musicians survived Wallis
body was one of the few recovered and
his leather music case was found
strapped to his body with his violin
inside on October 19 2013 Wallace
Hartley's violins sold at an auction for
the highest price ever paid for our
Titanic artifact one point four five
million dollars the most powerful point
of verification was the silver plaque
engraved with Wallace and Maria's names
did you know the Bible says that God
himself has engraved a special sign of
his love for us stay with his friends
were going to learn more on this edition
of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 72 97 that's
800 God says and I want to welcome our
friends who may be watching on Facebook
either the Doug Batchelor or amazing
facts Facebook page and we're glad that
you can tune in here and see what we
look like Sunday if we forget to shave
but we're glad that we can come to you
my name is Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross good evening frames and pastor
Doug let's start the program with prayer
dear father name we thank you once again
for the opportunity for us to gather to
give and open up your word and study we
do pray for your blessing on the program
this evening be with our listeners
wherever they might be and Lord as we
search the Scriptures we ask for the
Holy Spirit to lead us let me ask this
in jesus name amen amen
I fasted I opened the program this
evening by sharing an interesting fact
connected with the Titanic now of course
there's all kinds of relics that have
probably been pulled up from the the
ocean in the bottom of the you have one
here in the office so you have one
yourself general if you remember I got a
little piece I got a kind of titanic
shrine in my office a little piece of
coal oh they were covered hygenic yeah
sorry yeah but it is fascinating that
you know these different I've seen
knives that were gathered from the
Titanic and spoons and plates and they
sell them at auction they make a lot of
money but 1.4 million dollars for the
violin probably because of the
the attachment of the story that goes
along with it and the fact that they
were you know engaged to get married and
lost his life and it's just a lot
involved in that story so to summarize
the tragedy of the Holi game it's the
only instrument that survived because
the others were destroyed you know in
the depths eighty-five years underwater
but they they found Wallis and the
violin just a few days after the the
tragedy but and what made it so valuable
was the engraving mmm and you know the
Bible tells us that God cannot forgive
us because he's engraved his name and
his love on it on his hands his love for
us you can read in Isaiah 49 16 God says
behold I have engraved you on the palms
of my hands we think of the love that
the Lord has for us and that he's
engraved it with the crucifixion through
the scars in his hands but even when you
get to Revelation it tells us that
everybody in Revelation seems they have
something engraved in their forehead or
some identifying mark I even talks about
Babylon this woman and graved in her
forehead she's got a virtual paragraph
and the people who have the mark of the
beast but it's not just the loss that
have an engraving the saved have the
seal of God the name of God written in
their foreheads and sometimes it's
referred to as the seal of God and you
can find a reference to this if you look
in Isaiah chapter 8 verse 16 bind up the
testimony seal the law among my
disciples this harkens back to when God
said through Moses that the laws of God
should be in our hearts we should bind
them for a sign on our hand and they
should be as frontlets between our eyes
remember the high priests of Israel he
had a plaque on his mantle his hat that
said holiness to the Lord and so being
in the forehead it meant in the mind
there's something there now I'm not
going to say anymore because we want
people to study this out for themselves
but I'll bet a lot of folks out there
would like to understand what is this
engraving in the forehead Revelation
talks about the mark of the beast and
the seal of God what does that mean is
it literal is everybody getting a tattoo
in the last days we have a lesson that
talks about that we will send you for
free the lesson is called and the mark
of the beast not only talking about the
mark of the beast but also the seal of
God is all contained in this one lesson
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who calls an ass is part of our amazing
facts study guides series it's called
the mark of the beast the number to call
if you'd like to receive this is one
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven that is our resource phone
line just ask for the study guide called
the mark of the beast
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
calls and asks well pastor like we
really go to the phone lines our first
caller this evening is James listening
from Florida James welcome to the
program thank you hi thanks your call
your question I'm sorry dr. John thank
you so much for having me the particular
question that I have this evening I was
wanting to get some biblical clarity on
that my wife and I have a difference of
opinion on she has biblical references
to you know support her side I have to
support my side and that's on the
subject of the right to own a firearm or
again for strictly defensive reasons the
scripture that she relates to I want to
do my best to support her side and speak
for her
she likes to quote the Nauticus cemani
when Peter had drew his sword and cut
off malkos is a year and Jesus said that
he who lives by the sword dies by the
sword in that in possessors of whether a
weapon is just asking for trouble
Maya pain was everything because Peter
had used a weapon in an offensive manner
to attack someone
that's what Jesus was condemning not so
much that it's removed on the sword if
someone happens to attack you so curious
about your thoughts on that side yeah
well it is a great question and thanks a
lot for getting me in the middle of a
marital dispute I'm not because I know
I'm gonna make some bad but now let me
give you some Bible principles that's
alright just teasing
let me give you some Bible principles
personally if a person lives by the
sword that's obviously not Christian you
know the Bible tells us that blessed are
the peacemakers and jesus said you know
to Pilate he said if if my kingdom was
of this world then my servants would
fight Jesus did not want the disciples
to try to take and spread the power of
his kingdom using weapons though he said
I've come to send a sword but he meant
his word and so the word is a sword in
that sense but that's really a different
question from is it wrong or is there
some moral dilemma with a Christian
having a weapon that is used for
self-defense now there's there's a lot
of different scenarios our family pastor
Ross has been there we have a ranch
cabin way up in the hills and we're wild
animals everywhere and so I've got a
pistol when I head up there I always try
to keep a pistol handy you know we
literally see bears and mountain lions
and rattlesnakes and if nothing else you
fire in the air and you can scare them
off
one of my neighbors got within six feet
of a bear a couple weeks ago and so you
know it's a practical tool in that
setting some people live in the city and
they're concerned you know is there
gonna be an intruder well if their idea
is that they might use it as defense
there's nothing wrong
biblically there is a story that if a
strong man guards his house that you
know he's able to protect it if a thief
comes in he can try and conquer you know
Christians I don't think she'd ever be
taking up arms and it should be a last
resort to use something like that and to
defend your family or in a situation
like that you certainly wouldn't want to
keep them safe and out of the reach of
children but I don't think we should
live by the sword I don't think we
should live by guns or try and conquer
for Christ or help me pastor Ross am I
making sense well I think it's like it's
a good question and each person probably
needs to prayerfully consider you know
Paul says if I fail my brother
in doing this I'd rather be framed I
think when it deals with that if
somebody has a sensitive conscience and
doesn't want yeah
when Organa loves your wafer maybe yeah
some compromise needs to be there but
there are good Christians who do have a
firearm and yeah you know they do use it
for self defense if they need to it has
nothing wrong with that
if you're in some kind of law
enforcement there is a scripture where
Paul says that he the sheriff or is the
Minister for good
he does not bear the sword in vain in
other words they expected that the
police and the soldiers back then that
you know help keep the peace they were
armed and so we don't want any Christian
officers out there to think there's some
moral dilemma for that but as pastor
Ross said you know a lot of good
Christians take the position you know
we're just going to trust the Lord and
we're not going to use anything to have
a weapon for self-defense and others
feel differently so it's really a
personal choice ok did you still with us
James we might need to get James off and
back on again James you there can you
hear us James yes yes ok we lost you for
a second so I don't know if that helps
at all it helps now I had more of a
question towards other scriptures that I
had felt was kind of along the side of
my opinion on the matter and I wanted to
get an opinion on a scripture reference
which is in Luke 22 when you guys get
there I'll actually recite the verse
okay we're there okay verse 36 I'm
reading from do King James and he's
gonna come but now he has a money bag
let him take it and likewise a knapsack
and he who has no sword let him sell His
garment and buy one and then down in
verse 38 it says so they said Lord look
here are two swords and he said to them
it is enough yea it was Jesus saying
there are two swords is all you're gonna
need to take on the Romans or the the
temple guard coming to arrest you no
because when Peter pulled out a sword
Jesus had put your sword away when Jesus
said it is enough he didn't mean it's
enough weapons actually that translates
enough of this in other words when he
said
he that has a garment sell it and buy a
sword he was speaking of the sword of
the word back then Jesus was not
implying that we need to go get swords
to fight to spread the kingdom or defend
ourselves in that way so that verse I
don't think is talking about the
disciples aren't arming themselves
because Jesus clearly tells Peter to put
his sword away after he cuts off the
year of Malchus so you are you hopefully
that helps a little bit and it is a
great question you know we ought to add
it to our list of oh oh yeah I hope so
it helped up greatly on my life well we
hope you have domestic bliss
it would probably got to get to another
call and thank you so much yes sir all
right bye-bye thank you have a great
evening
take care my next call is also calling
from Florida and we have Chris on the
phone Chris welcome to the program yeah
hi hello yes my question is for Victoria
J book of Zechariah yeah it's tougher
twelve okay when you take comes chapter
12 in verse 8 10 okay want me to read
please
it says in Zechariah 12 verse 10 and I
will pour on the house of David and on
the inhabitants of Jerusalem the spirit
of grace and supplication and the look
on me who may have pierced yes they'll
mourn for him as one mourns for his only
son and grieve for him as one grieves
for a firstborn they just adversity
talks are poetry about Jesus correct I
believe it's a prophecy about Christ yes
about Christ okay and the part of my
question is also the first five books of
the Bible say the Jews are called Tara
correct the Pentateuch the first five
books and the Pentateuch are part of the
Torah but what's the heart of your
question is that Araya
the Prophet that they accept
in their Bible well yeah the the
Zechariah is part of the Jewish canon of
Scripture so most even liberal jurors
accept that the book of Zechariah is a
Jewish prophecy
alright Christians get over the Jewish
Scriptures okay so you're wondering how
they don't know how is that they don't
recognize this as a powerful prophecy of
Christ's contract yeah there's not only
this one
Zacharias got a great one where it talks
about his hands are pierced you've also
got Isaiah chapter 53 which is very
clear about he's suffering for our sins
and being led like a lamb to the
slaughter so there are a number of
prophecies that make some Orthodox Jews
very uncomfortable because they do seem
to vividly point out Christ and there's
a number of the Psalms that actually
talk about Christ's suffering in his
death as well yeah you know we have a
book that I think you'll enjoy that
talks a little bit about this and it's
called spiritual Israel we talked about
some of the prophecies there that point
to Christ and you know we actually have
a series now I think they can watch it
online and it's talking about is Jesus
kosher for Jews that I did whether to
other Jewish speakers and you can just
go probably YouTube and watch that but
we go ahead yeah if you'd like to
receive a free copy of the book called
spiritual Israel the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven
you can ask that book called spiritual
Israel we'd be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks or go to
youtube and look how pastor Doug
Batchelor is Christ kosher for Jews yeah
and you'll be able to watch that very
interesting discussion about
Christianity and Judaism I think you'll
enjoy it and let's see a 3G is talking
about how we accepted Christ right
absolutely
thank you for your call Chris how next
caller is Bill and he is listening in
Chicago bill welcome to the program I
passed your dog Pastor John good evening
yes evening I'm I'm calling because I
have kind of a weird question
um I have an aunt who brought us into
church I'm in back when I was five and
I'm like 54 now okay and she she spent
her entire life working for church from
working for God as a matter of fact she
didn't even get married till she was 79
well that's being careful she used to
say and I hope I don't start a problem
by saying this but it's been bugging you
for years I just can't find an answer
and my mother said she's looked in Bible
so many times and she can't find an
answer either and she didn't know why
she would say this but she used to say
that we were not supposed to have
anything do black people she said except
to say hello goodbye and to pray for
them because they were and eternally
curse traits by God but can't seem to
find it anywhere no that's not alive
under you yeah you know what there
there's a there's an urban legend out
there that when Noah pronounced a curse
on him that Noah and his wife had three
children and one was I guess Asian one
was at Black or African and one was
Caucasian and that it's just a really
elementary absurd interpretation it's
not true
Noah's children were all related we
don't get the three races from Noah's
children the races actually slowly
divided long after the Tower of Babel as
different tribes developed and went to
different parts of the world and through
intermarriage certain genetic
differences became viable the curse of
ham is not a curse on any particular
race so she said that your dear aunt was
wrong and as she struggles with some
prejudice I guess I didn't have any idea
but it just could never seem to find it
and I my mother said she could never
find it yeah they're referring to the
Christmas yeah it's pretty and where's
that Genesis chapter 9 I think we will
look it up for you but of course we
don't believe that we don't believe
that's what it's talking about but I've
heard that who I was I didn't understand
you know and I finally got one past
he said that he thought that it wasn't
in the Bible but that it was referred to
in Alan G White's writings but say have
no worries no in general absolutely
absolutely not so if you look you find
it in Genesis chapter 9 verse 24 and
that's where they get it it says you
know Chris B Canaan a servant of
servants shall he be to his brethren
that's just talking about a curse that
came on him because of his disrespect
for his father but that was not a
particular race Shem ham and Japheth
were all the same race they were all
brothers
so anyway yep that's a myth all right
next caller that we have is Joseph
listening from Dubai
Joseph welcome to the program hi evening
evening and your question my question is
yeah it's on Revelation chapter two and
three the seven churches and does it
also apply to the church in the Old
Testament starting from Abraham Isaac
and Jacob all the way to Malachi is that
okay well of course the the message to
the seven churches came after the era of
the Old Testament so it says in
Revelation for the time is at hand so
the starting point for the things you
find in Revelation is the time of John
and the New Testament church and so you
know there are similarities that you
would find in the messages that come to
the church and things that ancient
Israel went through but it's mostly
talking about the the seven ages or
phases the church goes through seven
epochs between the time of Jesus first
coming in the second coming why don't
you add to that yeah absolutely the
whole book of Revelation not just seven
churches but the whole book of
Revelation deals primarily with that
2000 year period from the Ascension of
Christ all the way through to the second
coming and beyond yeah so I hope that
helps a little bit Joseph and you would
probably enjoy our Bible study series
going through Revelation
you can take a look at the amazing facts
website and it's a seven part series
just gives an overview of Revelation we
talked about the seven churches and the
seven messages there next caller that we
have is Becky listening from Michigan
Becky welcome to the program oh hi Becky
yes Grand Ledge Michigan yes how are you
doing great how are you I'm doing fine I
have a new point I have a question how
do you overcome frustration I have a
real low intolerance I never struggle
with this I was a little kid
what are you struggling with frustration
oh just frustration huh yeah I might
have a disability at the struggle ever
since I was a little kid well first of
all the the Bible tells us that God does
answer prayer he does heal and transform
hearts and you know I think that God can
the human mind is incredible in that God
can teach us gradually to to overcome
all kinds of problems doubts you know
frustrations anxiety and you know
through prayer all of us are born with a
certain amount of inherited and some
were cultivated tendencies that drag us
down and through the power of God many
of these things can be overcome so do
you have you seen progress in your life
alright yeah well if the very fact
you've seen progress if you see that
you're able to learn if you see you're
able to grow the Bible has a lot to say
about God giving us grace to develop
self-control and to have faith and to
have peace all of us struggle to have
more of these things it sounds like
you've been really challenged in that
area but he can give it to you if you've
seen progress then just keep believing
he will give you more okay all right
Vicki he thank you and we'll be praying
that God helps you to see some
encouragement there next quote that we
have is Jared listening from
Tennessee Maryville Tennessee Jared
walking with the program yes and your
question my question was Jeremiah II 15
and 16 I it mentions that the showers
the latter rain is withheld and then it
mention something about I would give you
pastures which shall feed you knowledge
and understanding supposedly about the
next verse talking about the Ark of the
Covenant of the Lord shall not be done
any more that should not be visited is
that going to be a part of the latter
rain in the future or no now tell me one
more time Jeremiah what chapter were you
in chapter 3 15 okay here Maia chapter 3
in verses 3 15 and 16 okay and I'll give
you shepherds according to my heart who
feed you with knowledge and
understanding and verses three where
talks about and therefore the showers
have been withheld and there's been no
latter rain and you have a harlots
forehead and you refuse to be ashamed
it's interesting it mentions afar
harlots forehead which we find in
revelation 17 a harlot with something
written in her forehead which is that
was talking about stubbornness and
rebellion against God and when Jeremiah
says lift your eyes up to the desolate
heights and see where have you not lain
with men they had idols on all of their
mountains to different gods and the Lord
said you shouldn't have idols and he
shouldn't worship other gods and he's
saying therefore the the rain is
withheld the blessings of God would help
but when they returned to the Lord and
they repented he's saying I will send
the former rain and the latter rain of
course that's a symbol for the holy
spirit that comes said and I'll give you
pastors that will feed the flock and you
know you had that of course during the
time of the Apostles during the former
rain and it happens again in the last
days during the latter rain before the
second coming and that latter rain is
also referenced in Zechariah
so am i answering what you're asking
yeah yeah that's really really great
information and I didn't know yeah I
didn't know if that had anything to do
with future reference or anything in our
future or it does in fact some of the
Apostles when they're preaching they
quote from Jeremiah and so I think that
that does apply well you can tell Jared
that we're gonna have to take a break
that just snuck right up on us but don't
go away friends just the time for
station identification and get a drink
of water we'll be back with more Bible
questions
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return in a moment
[Music]
every day we make hundreds of decisions
sometimes these choices are mundane what
will you have for breakfast or what were
you wear for work but sometimes these
decisions can have an eternal impact
like when you set up an estate plan that
supports God's work we need to move
quickly friends to ensure as many souls
as possible have the opportunity to make
decisions for Christ and when you choose
to include your evangelism values in
your estate plan today amazing facts can
do even more to expand God's kingdom
through your faithful stewardship I'd
like to offer you a free gift entitled
provide and protect which is a
tremendous resource telling about
life-and-death decisions connected with
your estate plan contact our planned
giving department at eight hundred four
three six two six nine five or visit
enduring legacy dot o-r-g and you can
have the peace of mind that comes from
knowing your house is in order in six
days God created the heavens and the
earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth calm have
you ever wondered how can I share Jesus
with my Jewish friends amazing faxes
recently produced a fascinating
three-part DVD series called is Jesus
kosher for Jews in these new programs
three Jews Steve Wahlberg Geoff sir
Minsky and myself relate our personal
encounter with a Christian faith so pick
up a copy today for yourself and share
one with your Jewish friends call 800
five three eight seven 275 or visit us
at AAF bookstore com to get yours every
Bible question you have answered moves
you one step closer to the fullness of
God's will for your life so what are you
waiting for
get the answers you need for a fuller
richer more confident life you're
listening to Bible answers live this
broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
phone call to our studio you'll also
hear us give out another number and
that's the resource line we even have
chaplains there who are willing to pray
with you if you have some special need
and we'll give that number out in just a
moment my name is Doug Batchelor my name
is John Ross and we really go back to
the four lines we have
the caller from Florida yesh suku and
your suku welcome to the program hi hi
how are you good thank you for calling
and your question yes okay so my
question oh my gosh I can't believe I'm
talking to see you guys with anyways my
question is I wanted to ask first the
dog who does he think the two witnesses
are in the book of Revelation chapter 11
all right that's a good question
revelation 11 much of a revelation 11 is
dedicated to talking about these two
witnesses before the throne of God and
and everyone's wondered who they are
some have thought is it Elijah and Enoch
because they didn't die and some have
said well you know the Bible says it's
appointed unto man wants to die and they
need to die so they got to come back
down to earth and they'll be slain no
that's not who it is others think is it
Elijah and is it Moses because Elijah
and Moses in the Bible have many of the
same characteristics well that's getting
closer
Elijah represents the prophets and Moses
represents the law the two witnesses are
the Word of God the law and the prophets
it's sometimes called the commandments
of God and the testimony of Jesus the
Word of God is often referred to in a
dual stereo nature you've got the 10
commandments on two tables of stone the
Bible says the Word of God is like a
double-edged sword
and so the two witnesses it tells us
they are like a lamp before the throne
of God well the Bible says thy word is
like a lamp unto my feet it says they're
like the two olive trees before the
throne of God and the olive trees it
used to give the oil it was a symbol for
the spirit that kept the light burning
and so the law the prophets a testimony
of the Spirit is what inspired the
prophets and you notice what these two
witnesses do it says they they call down
plagues well you got plagues in
Revelation in the New Testament and you
got plagues in the Old Testament and it
says that they could shut up the heavens
with droughts you've got drought and
famine and the new in the Old Testament
so it's really an allegorical
prophecy of the two witnesses and a war
that the devil fights on the Word of God
whether you call it the law and the
prophets or you call it you know Moses
is a symbol of law allied to the
prophets or if you call it the new in
the Old Testament but we have a book we
can offer on that to Yash Zuko is it am
I saying that right
yes and it's called who are the two
witnesses to get the book or you like to
just say you forgot all one 883 five six
seven four seven and you can ask for the
book called who are the two witnesses
again that number is 885 six seven four
seven and I think we're ready for our
next caller
we got widely listening California why
they walked with the program
why the year here okay I need to know
when we get our mortal bodies on will
they mean flesh bodies yes good question
a quick answer is yes they are spiritual
and they are real when Jesus rose from
the dead and pastor oz might find it for
me in Philippians where it says our body
will be fashioned like unto his glorious
body when Jesus rose from the dead and
he appeared with his glorified body to
the disciples he was also real somehow
he could be invisible if he wanted to
but he he said touch me feel me see that
I am NOT a ghost and then he ate in
front of them to try to emphasize he was
real when God made Adam and Eve they
were real but they lived in four
dimensions they could talk to God they
could see angels after they send their
garments of light went out they lost
their spiritual dimension and they
became purely physical bodies but we
will have a combination of spiritual and
physical bodies like Adam and Eve had in
the garden and that verse in Philippians
yeah that's Philippians chapter 3 and
verse 21 that talks about that yeah now
we have is it our lesson on death talks
about the kind of bodies will have s
talks about the resurrection and will be
able to send it to anyone
calls and asks its called odd the dead
really dead that's the name of the yesan
and it does talk about the resurrection
talk about what its gonna be like when
Jesus comes again to receive that study
guide the number to call is 883 five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
amazing facts study guide called are the
dead really dad our next call he's
mapped and he's listening from New York
welcome to the program
Matt you've probably got turned your
radio down as you are live oh hey you're
on the air welcome okay well thanks for
having me on
um hey so I I just want a quick question
I was a church leader about six years
ago I've since you know walked away
thinking it was sort of innocent in the
beginning and then I just you know I
didn't realize you know how fast life
was going to you know kind of take over
and it just kind of one one thing led to
another and and you know Here I am six
years later now looking through old you
know messages from mine from back in 12
2012 2011 it's just kind of like you
know wondering how do i how does how do
you get back how to have it yeah how do
you get back and what you know like I
mean I know the Bible verses um you know
confessing to God and then forgiving you
but it's you know emotionally and
spiritually it's kind of like it's it's
hard to it's hard to recover that what I
once had that fervor and that that's a
great question and you know I'm I'm
thankful you're asking that question
because it sounds like you want to get
back that first love yeah I do it's like
I go back and forth it's like it it's
really art all right well first of all
don't be surprised that it's hard
there's a story in the Bible that when
Mary and Joseph made their first trip to
the temple with Jesus when he was 12
years old as they were heading home they
lost track of Jesus because they figured
he was just somewhere in the parade
heading back to Nazareth and when they
finally found him three days later they
said son we have spent three days
sorrowing searching to find you again
when we lose track of Christ it
sometimes means we need to retrace our
steps if you read in Revelation it's in
chapter 2 where Jesus gives a message to
the Church of Ephesus
he said if you lose your first love you
need to repent and do the first works
you need in other words you need to kind
of go back and and cover that same
ground read the things that stirred your
heart when you gave yourself to Jesus
about being born again about the
forgiveness and you know where you spent
20 minutes on your knees praying you may
need to spend 40 minutes on your knees
praying so it's you know it's you get a
little callus on your heart when you
wander way after knowing the Lord but
you definitely can come back and there's
many examples in the Bible of people
that did it you know Peter denied Jesus
and it says he went out and wept
bitterly so you know there there may be
a struggle don't get discouraged but you
persistent coming back and you know what
he will give you that first love again
okay so okay go get some good gets you
know read your Bible each day spend
quality time in prayer be deliberate
about praying even if you don't feel
like it get some good spiritual books
that will inspire you I love reading
testimonies and you'll find there's some
testimonies of Christian leaders that
wandered from the Lord and came back and
that I think will encourage you yeah I
had testimony he's like yeah like is
there like a compilation of something
that you have compiled or just you know
google it kind of look it out well you
know I I you can listen sometimes I'm
driving I just listened to the testimony
of David Livingstone and he felt like a
failure as a pastor he ended up becoming
one of the great explorers had opened up
Africa for all the other missionaries
you've got you know George Mueller who
wandered from the Lord and he ended up
becoming that one a great Christian of
Prayer and you've got John Newton who
his mother you know he's raised a
Christian he turned from God became an
atheist and a slave-trader got converted
on a slave ship when it was sinking yes
so you know there's just a few to start
with so I can think of probably hundreds
okay time to tell you all but yeah look
up just even Google
great Christian testimonies you'll see
some wonderful stories up there hey
thanks appreciate our question and we'll
be trained I get that new beginning that
first love my next caller that we have
is mark listening in Michigan mark
welcome to the program oh thank you my
question is my question is in genesis
9:4
it talks about not eating blood and I
was just wondering a lot of times when
God's God gives laws and Commandments it
really translates to a blessing
physically why you want to avoid certain
things so is there a a how do you
reconcile these days when they have
blood transfusions that might be a
ridiculous question but I'm just trying
to see what was behind that question and
transform yeah I'm glad you're asking
this because a lot of Christians are
oblivious today they think that all the
health laws have been abolished and it's
very clear there in Genesis chapter 9 as
well as the New Testament in Acts
chapter 15 you can read in verse 20 that
he says you command those who have
turned to God from among the Gentiles
write to them that they had stained from
things polluted by idols from sexual
immorality from things strangled and
from blood now the things strangled and
blood goes together when they butchered
an animal a clean animal to eat it that
cut its throat they drain all the blood
out they were not to eat blood that
eating blood is very different from a
blood transfusion you're not hearing
blood as a dietary thing matter of fact
I could say someone who passed the
Rosses family probably would not be
alive if it wasn't for a blood
transfusion more than one and so what
transfusions can save life eating blood
can transfer disease and hurt your
health so it does disease can be
transferred from animal to animal when
you ingest their blood the blood
transfusion of another human and good
health with the same blood type can save
a life and it's usually a last resort
people don't do that recreationally you
know what do you want to you know do for
lunch they ought to do a blood
transfusion I mean it's usually a
life-threatening
thing so I don't you know I know there's
some churches that teach there's a moral
problem with a blood transfusion but
that's not eating is it's a whole
different term okay very good thank you
by the way we're saved by virtue of a
blood transfusion the blood of Christ
mm-hmm all right hey thank you great
question
next color that we have is amber amber
you on the air
hi this is Amber and I had a question
about well first of all hi how are you
doing hi thank you for calling and your
question we're excited to hear it oh
okay so I've been having dreams like
like ever since I was like a child like
I can remember some my dreams from like
probably before I can even talk uh-huh
like I still remember my dreams and I
remember them being very vivid and real
like and more of like I would say some
dreams that I would dream about like 20
years ago are now coming true and and
maybe like the future like the end of
the world type stuff and you know are
you wondering at some of them are like
divine or prophetic yes I'm wondering if
they are prophetic in I feel like some
of them are because I've had them over
20 years ago and they're coming true and
they're still coming true
and I do feel like the Holy Spirit is
confirming these so my dreams and I just
kind of was wondering like what does the
Bible say about dreams I know the enemy
can give dreams too and I can kind of
tell the difference between yeah I can
kind of tell the difference between his
dreams and God's dreams and so yeah I
want to know it could I be a prophet or
how like what does the Bible say about
dreams all right well that's a great
question
first of all that God does give dreams
and you're right the devil can give
dreams that we usually call them a night
mirror you can read in the book of Joel
I think it's chapter two pastor Ross
where it says the old men will dream
dreams and young men will see visions
and also on maintenance and handmaidens
I will pour out my spirit with Joel 2:28
Joel 2:28 does say that you know dreams
will be given in the last days you never
used a dream to be a substitute for the
word and keep in mind it does also say
in Ecclesiastes and I have to type in
the word multitude of business I forget
where in Ecclesiastes because I'm a
little bit dyslexic with numbers but it
says a dream comes through the multitude
of business in other words if if you
spend a lot of time playing chess you
might dream of a chess board you spend a
lot of time you know hanging out with
certain friends they may be in dreams if
you spend time worrying about last day
events you might dream about the
tribulation so yeah I can't tell you
that your dreams are prophetic because
you know how you know if a dream is
prophetic is it the Bible says that
these things are best understood after
they come true so first of all you want
to follow the Word of God the Lord maybe
sharing dreams with you usually when he
gives somebody supernatural dreams like
joseffer they may also have the gift of
interpretation and I don't have that
gift so I couldn't tell you I've got it
sometimes a dream can come from eating
the wrong thing before you go to bed so
you know just just sit back and say Lord
if this is from you you'll have to just
show me and there'll be confirmation
that will come and we actually have a
lesson that will tell you if you matter
of fact does be a great idea because in
that lesson if I'm not mistaken pastor
Ross
it will help amber identify what are the
criteria of biblical prophet it's called
strange title it says does God inspire
stralla gist sand psychics Hannah talks
about the genuine gift of prophecy and
how it's manifest in the Bible I will be
happy to send it to anyone who calls an
ass and I think amber you'll find this
interesting to read again just after the
study guide on does God inspire psychics
and
we'll be happy to send that to you
there's a number of tests that can be
applied to dreams and visions to make
sure that they are indeed coming from
God mm-hmm a next caller that we have is
Robert listening in Washington Robert
Walker program
hey righto you're on welcome and your
question okay yes I was calling to ask
about this question I've been wondering
about for a while it's an isaiah 28
verses 10 through 13 okay for precept
must be upon precept precept upon
precept line upon line line upon line
here a little there a little that what
you're wondering
uh-huh someone told me anyway that
according to this these verses verses 10
and 13 that when you study the Bible
you're falling back because if you put
verse 13 with it it says that they might
go and fall backward and be broken and
snared and caught so I keep hearing from
this one person that it's not good to
study the Bible
here a little Darrell oh no I
of course everything else in the Bible
tells you it's a blessing to study the
word we're commanded to study the word
jesus said search the Scriptures these
are they that testify of me absolutely
you know the Jewish people back in the
time of Isaiah sometimes were arguing
they were they were teaching in their
schools but they weren't living it in
their lives and Christ said you know
these people draw near to me with their
lips but their hearts are far from me
there's nothing wrong with studying
precept upon precept matter of fact in
Daniel it says many will run to and fro
and knowledge will increase well as you
go to and throw to and fro through the
Scriptures your knowledge increases
comparing spiritual things with
spiritual and it's good to compare
Scripture with Scripture but you know I
say it's dealing with a time some of the
Kings he dealt with like Manasseh they
they had a lot of religion but they were
very corrupt during that time I think we
also need to recognize that there are
those who will twist the scriptures to
their own destruction as you read in the
New Testament it is possible for someone
to take one verse out of context and
maybe build a doctrine and it's country
to what other passages of scripture
might seem to be saying so we need to
compare Scripture with Scripture and
follow the principles don't just take
one verse and build a doctrine around it
but compare scripture on that theme
throughout scripture to say you know
safe you know if you read a little
further on among in that same passage
Robert it says therefore thus says the
Lord God verse 16 I will lay in Zion a
stone for foundation a tried stone a
precious cornerstone a sure foundation
tried precious sure whoever believes
will not act hastily he then says
basically that there's a foundation
cornerstone that is going to be the the
bottom line of all that we measure truth
by and that is of course the Word of God
Jesus said he that hears these words of
mine and does them is building on the
rock and so the Word of God is a rock
and so right after them saying you know
we're gonna argue precept after precept
he says you know it's all gonna be based
on the rock of God's Word
but I think we've got a free book we can
send you if you'd like and it says is
there anything left you can trust love
the Word of God to receive the book
called you left today just give us a
call on our resource phone line that
number is 885 six seven four seven and
again you can ask the book called is
there anything left you can trust and
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks we've got Yvonne
listening from Michigan Yvonne welcome
to the program hello hi thank you for
calling you're welcome thank you for
listening to me had a question for
pastor Doug
two questions okay
the question that my husband has which
is Kurt you need to turn probably your
radio off in the background in the back
yeah the way it continued by the delay
I'll do that sorry all right can you
hear me I can my husband pastor Doug
wants to know it and he absolutely loves
your humor and he loves it when you get
going from one after the other so he
wants to know where he can apply for a
job when you're going on your next
journey Oh be fun to work together huh
oh yeah he's quite a card but secondly
most importantly for me I would like to
know when the Sunday law comes into
effect what are our duty is to be as
Christians what do what are we supposed
to do where are we supposed to go yeah
well let me help explain your question
to our other listeners we got listeners
from all different backgrounds and and
you know in Revelation when it talks
about worshiping the Beast in His image
we remember that in Daniel chapter 3
Shadrach Meshach and Abednego ahead to
make a decision are we gonna break the
law of God or keep the law of the king
and they had to decide do I break the
law about idolatry that's the second
commandment in Daniel chapter 6 Daniel's
got to make a decision do I obey the law
the first commandment don't have other
gods or do I worship King Darius and he
decided to go to the lion's den rather
than disobey the day is gonna come where
God's people are gonna be tested on the
fourth commandment and there may be laws
that compel people to go to church on a
day other than the Bible Sabbath and
they call that the Sunday law well you
know during that time as with all times
in histories it's like Peter said we
ought to obey God rather than men and so
we just pray that God will give us
faithfulness now the day may come where
a you know persecution during the time
of the beast power may be severe and we
may have to flee to more desolate places
but in the meantime we want to says when
the abomination of desolation is set up
let those that be
Judea flee into the mountains in the
meantime we want to be as busy as we can
reaching as many as we can with the good
news do we have time for one more quick
question pastor Ross you see a promising
short one yes we've got Daniel listening
from New York
Daniel working with the program Daniel
you're on the air
we got about one minute what's that we
got about a minute so what's your
question
I was just wondering who what the last
name was or the very first person on
earth and who named it who named him
that who named her that okay well you
know we get our last names are often
derived from the places where we live
and from our occupation someone might be
named you know Bill Miller and that's
because her family were Millers and E
someone might be carpenter they were the
carpenters others might be Jesus of
Nazareth because it was where they came
from and so last names usually were a
descriptive name about the family to
help you identify it especially in you
know places like Israel where so many
people have the name Judah is not only
Judas Iscariot there were several Judas
where Jesus had a brother named Judah
and it was very common name so they
would also give you another descriptive
name from this place or from this
occupation Jesus the carpenter they
would say and so the last names
typically came from occupation to help
identify people now Adam and Eve didn't
have last names because they weren't
going to be confused with anybody else
in the early days and so interesting
question I think that's the first time
we've had that Iran thank you so much
for your question and listening friends
you know we have a great website it's
called Bible prophecy truth we started
out with some questions about Bible
prophecy tonight if you have any more
questions on that go to Bible prophecy
truth dot-com
you'll find it talks about angels
millennium raptures second coming all
the great exciting themes of Bible
prophecy Bible prophecy truth calm and
please bear with us a moment longer as
we remind you this program is only on
the air because people like you
listening say I want to be a friend of
amis
facts you'd like to know more how you
could support this ministry keep us on
the air we sure appreciate it all you
have to do is go to amazing facts
dot-com we have a brand new website and
you can donate right there online for
those of you who are savvy with your
phones we're very excited amazing fax
has just released a handy dandy sharp
tech savvy app for your phone and so it
works both with the Android and with the
Apple phones and just type in amazing
facts ministry into the App Store and
you can download our app we're gonna be
chased off by the music don't leave
until you hear are important closing
announcements god bless thank you for
listening to today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
amazing facts offer some of the best
Christian resources for all ages we have
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the Lord
what does Bible prophecy reveal about
the world's two largest religions
explore the ancient conflict in Islam
Christianity and prophecy a compelling
three-part series with pastor Doug
Batchelor get yours today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767
connected with your estate plan contact
our planned giving department at eight
hundred four three six two six nine five
or visit enduring legacy dot o-r-g
and you can have the peace of mind that
comes from knowing your house is in
order one to know God's plan for our
world and solutions for your life's
challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts
twenty-seven Bible study guides provide
encouraging Bible based answers to
questions on healthier relationships
when Jesus will return and much more
refer to watch while you read our brand
new prophecy encounters DVD series makes
the perfect companion set order your
study guides and DVDs today by visiting
AAF bookstore calm or by calling 858
seven two seven five four life-changing
Christian resources this @af bookstore
calm
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at www.ge.com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at
you